[Music]
in this flat commonplace mono syllable
has contained the wisdom of the
government the abstract intelligence of
the universal will in the fulfilling of
itself the government is itself nothing
else but the self established focus or
the individuality of the universal will
the government which wills and it
executes its will from a single point at
the same time wills and execute a
specific order an action on the one hand
it excludes all other individuals from
its act and on the other it thereby
constitutes itself a government that is
a specific will and so stands opposed to
the universal will consequently it is
absolutely impossible for it to exhibit
itself as anything else but a faction
what is called government is merely the
victorious faction and in the very fact
of it being a faction lies the direct
necessity of its overthrow and its being
government makes it conversely into a
faction and so guilty when the universal
will maintains that what the government
has actually done as a crime committed
against it the government for its part
has nothing specific and outwardly
apparent by which the guilt of the will
opposed to it could be demonstrated for
what stands opposed to it as the actual
universal will is only an unreal pure
will intention being suspected therefore
takes the place or has a significant
significance and effect of being guilty
and the external reaction against this
reality that lies in the simple
inwardness of intention consists in the
cold
matter-of-fact annihilation of this
existent self from which nothing else
can be taken away but its mere being
paragraph 591 is rather short but
there's a lot going on here that needs
to be unpacked in terms of the
historical situation and the transitions
that we've made up to this point in
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit so
there's really a lot to be said here
about what Hegel himself is saying and
very very quick outlined you might say
fill in the blanks kind of terms let's
do some of that filling in the blanks
here so let's think for a moment about
what this section is fundamentally about
this is kind of a lynchpin right in the
middle of this short absolute freedom
and terror section which is essentially
about the Enlightenment and it's it's
you might say highest point and also
lowest point in the French Revolution
which occurs before Hegel writes this as
a matter of fact the terror also
occurred but the effects of the French
Revolution are continuing at the time
that Hegel is writing this in the
Napoleonic Empire and in a sort of
reworking of the entirety of Europe
insofar as you know the world spirit on
horseback is the proverbial expression
for Napoleon is able to to reimpose a
kind of order now he's not going to come
up at this point but we should keep that
in mind instead think about the
transformations that are happening
within the French Revolution and if you
remind yourself about what you may have
you know read or heard or learned in
history class the French Revolution
starts out as a revolution against the
French monarchy but also against the two
other estates which are connected with
it and those states are in the nobility
of which the king is you know the
highest level but all these other Nobles
all these are
to Kratts who enjoy privileges who get
to be involved in governance who have
you know their their own dimensa-zam
which they draw income and then we have
the entirety of the clergy the church in
this case the Catholic Church within
France
who again you know range from the
poorest friars dealing with with the the
people living in the slums and sharing a
life with them all the way up to very
powerful Cardinals and Abbot's and
bishops enjoying an incredibly luxurious
lifestyle
some of them completely estranged from
church doctrine or governance as we see
there's a lot of corruption going on at
the time the revolution goes against
those and you might say gradually
attempts to rip those out of French
society and replace them with
essentially a bourgeois society the
Society of the Third Estate we might
also include in this what we often call
the Fourth Estate the opinion formers of
the jerk you know the journalists and
newspapers the reviews of the time now
why would that turn into terror
well here's we're going to get to the
key question when you have a revolution
when you change the power structure
fundamentally very often this requires
violence this requires somebody to exert
power against somebody else those people
are not happy about losing their status
losing their power losing their wealth
losing whatever other distinctions we
might talk about even even if it's one
simply of rank impoverished aristocrats
or sometimes the most dangerous people
because they would like to at least
think of themselves as special because
they are aristocrats similarly in our
own time when we talk about those who
enjoy you know sort of the lowest form
of privilege the privilege of belonging
to
a semi privileged class where the people
at the top certainly enjoy it and the
people at the bottom get to say well at
least I'm not those people below me
Rousseau by the way identified this
entire dynamic and and discussed it at
great length in several of his own works
including if you want to check it out
the s the the discourse on the origin of
inequality among men
something that Hegel himself is is
reacting to in in these discussions and
why so because Russo's thought along
with that of others like the
encyclopedias was very important in
shaping the conceptions of those who are
involved in the world historical events
of the French Revolution coming back to
that now what happens during the French
Revolution we see that there are
alternate conceptions of how the new
society is supposed to be formed be
shaped take place who counts as a good
person and who counts as a bad person
who is a friend or an ally or a good
subject and who is an enemy we have the
problem of what is called faction and
you notice Hegel refers to that here and
we're going to talk about that in just a
moment and one faction will gain the
upper hand and suppress another faction
this happens quite frequently in
revolutions and the French Revolution
was you know no exception to this in
fact it even you might say set the tone
for it what ended up happening was the
moderate let's call them faction lost
power and the radical faction ended up
taking power and then putting people to
death sometimes exiling them but
oftentimes rounding people up and
guillotining them this started a
sequence in which gradually even those
who had initiated those policies
themselves
found that they became the victims of
those very policies once you start down
the you know hyper radical path and
start saying that revolutionary justice
allows for these very exceptional
policies it becomes very difficult to
you know pull the brake back and get the
machine to no longer lurch down the road
towards greater and greater tragedies of
that sort Hegel talks about that here in
the first sentence he says in this flat
commonplace mono syllable has contained
the wisdom the vice height of the
government what does the flat mono
syllable he's talking about
well that's referred to in the previous
paragraph he is talking about death in
German toad and this isn't just any sort
of death in the previous paragraph he
talks about this is being essentially a
meaningless death the sort of death that
has been stripped of significance a
death that is simply an effacement or an
erasure of those who are dying he uses
this metaphor of no more significance
than cutting off a head of cabbage
you're not even treating a human being
like a human being you're treating them
as if they are a mere impediment as if
they are an insect that you should
squash as if they are a blight on your
crop there's a dehumanization going on
here and this is very important to dwell
on for it for two reasons so the one
reason is there are many deaths that
could be quite significant and if we
think about the path that we've
traversed in the dialectic up until this
point all the way from you know the the
first clash of those two self
consciousness is in the fable that Hegel
was telling about the battle to the
death through the master-slave dialectic
the rest of self consciousness stoicism
skepticism unhappy consciousness the
entire reason section with all of its
speculative and practical compartments
and then the the massive spirit section
that we're still in the middle of
thinking about what we've traversed you
know from the beginning of spirit and
the struggle between the the individual
or the family and the city-state ends
sometimes the government and then
travelling into the culture section in
which we have wealth state power the
noble and base consciousness all of
these dialectics over and over and over
again and then finally a struggle once
culture had shown some of the neol ism
that was nascent within it we have a
struggle between faith and enlightenment
and faith wins I mean sorry
enlightenment wins things would have
been very different had faith wouldn't
they as a matter of fact if faith had
won we wouldn't have an advance of the
dialectic instead things would go back
to that point and wait for us to move on
ahead and we can say the same thing
about each point in the dialectic you
know one society may go this way another
society goes this way and it's where
there's a possibility of something new
something novel being worked out in
relation to what is the reality of the
time not just coming out of nowhere but
coming out of the previous conditions
that's where the dialectic advances and
so here returning back to this
particular paragraph and this particular
dialectic we have what's going on within
revolutionary France we have other
revolutions that have taken place the
British had a revolution in which they
actually wound up killing a king of
course they brought them back in later
on right it's not quite the same thing
Americans also had had a revolution by
this time in which they threw off the
British here we're also going to see
something kind of interesting playing
itself out and we can make comparisons
between the French and the
the American Revolution as it actually
took place not the storybook you know
picture that we present to ourselves
when we're teaching it to our kids but
something closer to the horrors war and
revolution the second thing that I think
is really important to think about here
is this Hagel talks about the wisdom of
the government the government is the
high gear on we've encountered this at
different points we saw this back in
earlier in the spirit section we've also
seen this brought up previously as well
not always called exactly the same thing
sometimes it's the lord of the world
sometimes it's it's framed in other ways
but it's a person who has the power or
the apparatus that has the power the
party the group of people how is death
some sort of wisdom well if you want to
get things done and you're going to
encounter opposition to those things you
will probably have to kill some people
now that may not be the case forever for
us human beings but it certainly is at
the points in history that Hagel is
thinking about by the way a little bit
of digression here if anybody ever tries
to tell you that everybody was more or
less in agreement having the same sort
of mindset back in ancient times
medieval times early modern times all
you have to do is like read some history
or study some Hegel to know that that's
bunk there is no idyllic State for us to
return to it was always conflict
conflict over some things and here the
conflict is over going to be what the
universal or if we want to use Russo's
terms general will is actually requiring
of us so again how can death be wisdom
of the government
here's where Hegel doesn't say this but
this is actually well worth thinking out
who does the government impose death
upon especially the kind of death that
we're referring to here where human
beings are reduced to mere ciphers and
then those are erased from the page
sometimes it's against what's perceived
as an external enemy you know the the
barbarians threatening your civilization
you can go and lay them waste and you
don't need to bother counting them up
except maybe to see what sort of payment
the soldiers need to get colonization
can work like that as well you impose
your rule on an area and then say all
right the rest of you are now subjects
of such-and-such and begin to eliminate
them in a dehumanizing way a way that
clears them out of there so that you can
take their their land their resources
whatever they have built up at the time
which may include you know all sorts of
agricultural products you know processes
trading routes any of those sorts of
things but we're governments once
government really starts to get
organized and has something like a
perceived legitimacy behind it where a
government really has the greatest
opportunity to do killing and reduction
of people down to nothing is with its
own subjects and this has happened time
and time again and this did happen
within the French Revolution it's kind
of a combination of sorts because some
parts of the French Revolution where
where mass killing was going on it was
much more like colonization where you
know not everybody in France was behind
the Revolution including many of the
common people who didn't want those
revolutionaries with their Parisian ways
telling them what to do
there was a struggle between the center
and the provinces sometimes very bloody
revolts were put down with with you
great what would you call it what we
call extreme prejudice
sometimes in any case the government is
particularly able to impose or at least
to threaten this death of a Faceman
against its own citizens and that is
what happens so Hegel goes on and he
says the wisdom of the government the
abstract intelligence of the universal
will the government is supposed to be
representing the universal will he says
in the fulfilling of itself why is the
government in place
well because it's supposed to be
enacting what the universal will wants
what is the universal will however it's
some sort of common good or if we want
to get away from the notion of good it's
sort of like an assemblage of all of the
Wills of the people involved in the
common wealth of the society whatever it
is that we're focusing on so the
government is is stepping in and doing
something concrete being real as we
could say now how does this play itself
out here's where we get into a
problematic dialectic he says the
government itself is nothing else but
the self established known as self
established not just they vote the
government in and everybody's like oh my
goodness what an honor I'll take this on
no you campaign to get power right
there's there's an element of of taking
it there he says the self established
focus or the individual individuality of
the universal will so here's a key thing
he says the government will x' and
execute its will from a single point now
does he mean always that it's like a
despotic ruler no it could be a
Politburo it could be a committee right
it could be an entire bureaucracy but it
has some sort of
commonality to it that allows itself to
be consolidated within a single point he
says it at the same time wills and
executes a specific order and action now
I wanted to dwell on this a little bit
specific be symptom why is is that
specific it is specific because it's
determined it's determinate
it's one thing to have a universal will
like we could say well you know what are
our general principles we want everybody
to be able to live a life free of
interference from other people you know
when that interference is irrational you
know obviously if I want to like burn
trash here in the center of Milwaukee
the cops should come along and say hey
buddy what are you doing there I don't
think that smoke should be blowing and
everybody else's faces but we have a
general principle like that that's fine
that's a universal will how do you enact
that how do you make that concrete it
has to be made determinate and that you
think you need a government to do that
you need somebody who's actually in
charge so a specific orden ordering and
on ordinal a way of structuring society
a way of differentiating people and then
action or comportment haand load right
and the government the reason I've got
you know more than one arrow here is
because the government is doing this
continuously it doesn't just do it once
and then everything is fixed and solved
and we just move on and get you know get
to the stuff that we really want to do
you know the government continuously has
to be involved in governance so he says
on the one hand what does this do it
excludes all other individuals from its
act so all the others don't get to be on
the same plane as the government this is
what it means to be sovereign right so
he says on the other hand it thereby
constitutes itself a government that is
a specific will
and so Stan's here's the here's where it
becomes more tragic opposed to the
universal will so it's supposed to be
fulfilling the universal will and in in
in order to do that it has to also at
the same time resist the universal will
by becoming determinate by becoming
specific the way it has to it places
itself in opposition
not just to these other others who've
been excluded but to the entire
universal will this means that
legitimacy is never entire it's never
finished it's never complete so he says
what's the result of this it's
impossible for it to exhibit itself as
anything else but a faction and here a
goal actually uses just the the you know
term Fox yawn this is an idea that's
been around for a very long time ancient
Greeks called this by the term fascist
and this is a central preoccupation for
ancient political theory because it
happened all the time
societies would break down into factions
sometimes we also use the word
partisanship for this as well so they're
sharing the same common social space but
they're jockeying and sometimes warring
and sometimes killing each other over
them the government becomes a faction
and it becomes as he says merely the
victorious faction so why can't the rest
of these people get together and say
let's become a faction ourselves let's
get rid of these bums and put a new set
in place who won't be bums they'll be
better there's always that promise that
we're going to do something that is
going to in fact realize the universal
will so if the people are starving and
the government says well it's because we
haven't had very good harvest and we're
trying to negotiate with those
monarchist enemies for some grain you
can get impatient with them and say
you know what they're doing they're
hoarding that bread just like those
aristocrats did before let's revolt
against them get rid of them and
guillotine them and by the way put me in
charge of that project won't you so he
goes on and he says the very fact of the
government being a faction in the very
fact of that lies that a direct
necessity of its overthrow oftentimes
people want to portray Hegel's
philosophy as if you know it's got this
thesis antithesis synthesis thing and
what's important about thesis and
antithesis is that you know you've got a
thesis and original thing and then
somehow out of it comes its opposition
in this case that's actually true there
is a antithesis that's coming out of the
you know self-same rejecting itself we
might imagine this happens through
purges or disagreements within the
faction that comprises the government
and then they agitate against them now
he goes on and he says being a
government also makes it into a faction
and so guilty everybody becomes guilty
within this society nobody's hands are
clean after a certain point so he
continues and he says when the universal
will maintains that what the government
has actually done is a crime committed
against it how is that going to happen
how does the universal will maintain
that the government is engaging in
crimes against the universal will some
of these others have to speak for the
universal will and insofar as the
government actually is guilty has
engaged in specific actions that can be
viewed in a negative light there's an
opportunity for that new faction to get
some power and to represent the
universal will if they succeed of course
what do you think is going to happen
well they become the next government and
this entire thing repeats again so he
goes on and he says
what the universal will maintains is
that what the government is actually
done as a crime committed against it the
government for its part has nothing
specific and outwardly apparent by which
the guilt of the will opposed to it
could be demonstrated for what stands
opposed to it as the actual universal
will is only an unreal pure will
intention what is he talking about there
well the others who speak for the
general will they don't actually have
the power they may have a different kind
of power maybe they control the press or
maybe they get the people behind them
but for the for the time being from the
perspective of the government they're
actually traitors and now we see that
death becomes you know not just an
option but almost an inevitability for
both sides so he goes on and he talks
about suspicions here being suspected
takes the place or has the significance
and effect of being guilty this is a
very important transition being
suspected takes the place of actually
being guilty what makes you actually
guilty well that you've done something
or that you can be demonstrated to have
done something what happens in
revolutions is that those who are even
suspected of having done something are
treated as if they are just as guilty of
having done it this runs throughout the
entire society and he says the external
reaction against this reality that lies
in the simple inwardness of intention
consists in cold matter-of-fact
annihilation of this existent being from
which nothing else can be taken away but
its mere being and again we see the sort
of dehumanizing of the opponent they're
not even really an opponent at that
point they've been reduced to something
like a mere obstacle that has to be
eliminated and so when we sketch this
out you see there's so much more
involved in this
paragraph when we think about the
implications and the historical
reference that Hegel has in mind here so
once again we see that absolute error is
going to culminate in death now are we
going to learn anything from that death
that's the key question for spirit
you